(audience cheering and whistling)
- Love you back.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for having me.
So I've been spending
the last couple of hours
meeting a bunch of people
here and it really allowed me
to kind of frame up where
I wanted to go with my talk
and I think the word that's
most populated to my mind
at this conference so far is patience.
I think that when I think
about block chain or crypto,
when I think about AR
and more importantly,
when I think about my career,
I think the word patience is something
that needs to be talked about here.
This afternoon has been
a lot of fun for me
because it's kicking me vibes
of the social media conferences
I went to in 2005, '06, '07.
It's kicking me vibes
to the feeling I felt
when I launched an eCommerce
wine business in 1996.
A lot of the conversations
today have been around
when does this go mainstream,
when is it accepted?
You know, when, how.
All these kinds of themes I've
seen two or three other times
that there was a time when
I went to search conferences
where people were like when's
search gonna be accepted
and then all the way
back to the beginning,
when would the internet
itself be accepted.
For all the youngsters
in here who are spending
a disproportionate
amount of time to justify
blockchain or crypto, I want to remind you
there was a time when the
internet itself was a fad.
The first conference I ever
went to that looked like this,
I sat in a Chamber of
Commerce event on a panel
where literally old people made fun of me
for 45 minutes because
they laughed at the idea
that people would buy wine on the internet
and multiple people on the panel I was on
said that by the year 2000,
the internet would not exist.
I really, I really want
to give a piece of advice
from an old-timer who's been through
a couple of cycles of innovation.
If you spent as much energy
that you spend on debating
whether crypto or blockchain
are going to succeed,
if you took that same energy
and actually became a practitioner
in the execution within your craft,
you would be much further along.
(audience cheers and applauds)
100%.
To me, debating who's
gonna win a basketball game
in the first quarter when
the game's actually gonna end
and there's gonna be a score
up there is kind of silly
in its nature so if I could
leave you with anything
from my perspective and there's
a lot of interesting people
speaking during this conference,
I would highly recommend
deploying a lot more patience.
You know, whether you're
right or they're right,
it's completely irrelevant.
It's gonna play out and we'll all
Monday morning quarterback.
A lot of times when people debate me
and I can just see that this
is just a religious debate.
There is no conversation.
It's not a debate, it's just an argument.
I often end with cool,
I'll see you in 2028.
Right, there's no other conversation
and so that's just one tidbit.
There's another tidbit.
99% of the browsers and
search engines that people
made lots of money on in valuation
in the mid '90s went out of business.
I think it's very important
for people in this space
to understand that it is likely
that 90-98% of the
currencies will not make it.
And so there's always
moments in time when there's,
and what's so incredible in the space is
there's liquidation along the way.
Unlike when I was investing
in early stage start-ups,
you invested and it was feast or famine.
There was no liquidation along the way
which is what attracted
a lot of the behavior
in this space, but I please,
I need people to understand.
To me, blockchain is a technology
as a foregone conclusion.
But the currencies that
are built on top of that,
have enormous volatility.
For all the people here
that like to tell each other
how they made a million
bucks in 12 months from zero,
I want everyone to know that
this is just my real life.
I have over 10,000 direct
messages and emails in my inbox
right now of people who
maxed all their credit cards
and bought bitcoin at 15,000, right,
who are in deep fucking shit,
who are in massive depression
and sadness so please understand
that when we're in these spaces,
there's enormous volatility
and it's very fucking early.
Like real early.
Like real fucking early and
I think the lack of patience
of proving you were right or
needing to make 10 million
bucks or whatever the
fuck is going through
your mind is the vulnerability.
The lack of patience in this collective,
all of us here together, all
the fancy people in the back
and all the people here,
our collective vulnerability
is lack of patience.
(audience applauds)
and so I genuinely believe that if you're
one of the two or three people here
who can fundamentally change your path
from the quick score because
of the gold rush nature
of the oxygen in the room to
do you actually believe in blockchain?
Do you believe in decentralization
and start being meaningful?
I believed in social media in 2006.
There was a lot of people
who came and went in
2006, '07, '08, '09, '10 who
had a lot of Twitter followers.
There's a substantial reason
that I was able to see it
all the way through and be in
this space with a longevity
because my behavior wasn't
held through a scale.
It wasn't, my pants were
on fire because I thought
that this social media thing
would be gone tomorrow.
I am completely convinced
and this is not a disrespectful comment.
I'm completely convinced
that more than half this room
thinks that it's a quick score game
and have no sense or
even are educated enough
to understand how this all plays out
and I think within that
is your opportunity
because I will say this.
For the group that's here,
you have such a substantial
advantage over 99% of people
because you understand that
this is actually even happening.
The 99% of the people in
the world understanding
of blockchain or crypto
is the word bitcoin
and that's where it starts and end.
99 in the collective 7.7 billion people.
Please do not underestimate the ability
of you being somewhere early like you are.
However, I just want people to take score
of what's actually
happening this weekend here
and what's the opportunity at hand.
I think the other thing that
I'm very passionate about
is understanding the media landscape
that we live in during this revolution.
Several people I know here intimately.
There's others that I know from afar.
I think the one great
opportunity for everybody here
is to understand what this
is actually all about, right?
Just understanding the
foundation of us living
in a mobile environment.
One thing that I think a lot of people
need to understand is how
to leverage the current
mobile social environment
in your crypto, AR
future technology worlds.
If you really look at
the history of people
that won or have had success
within new innovations,
they were able to leverage
the current main innovation
in a way to progress.
So many people here have
been able to be successful
in monetizing crypto
currencies on the back of
building personal brand
and being given tokens
in exchange for PR services or vlogging
or things of that nature.
Please understand we are
absolutely in the eye of the storm
of the golden era of social media.
Right now, we sit here
while Instagram story ads
are $2 CPMs and have
swipe up call to actions
and it's so uncomfortably underpriced
I don't even know what to do with myself.
I'm like pouring $100,000 a week into ads.
I don't even know how to
squeeze it any fucking harder.
So for a lot of people here,
so many of your ambitions
are predicated on you
communicating to the world.
Please don't do what most
people do which is they jump
to the next thing before they
squeezed the current thing.
One of the greatest mistakes in my career
happened in 2007.
I was literally one of
the first people ever
to produce a YouTube video
that was longer than five
minutes long, literally.
I had the longest consistent
long form show on YouTube
on 2006 and '07, but
because of my impatience
or because I chased economics,
a platform came along called Vidler,
which was a YouTube
competitor and offered me
7% of the company to move my show,
Wine Library TV to Vidler.
I did that because it seemed ridiculous.
7%, it seemed like a great deal,
but what I left on the table
was my deep understanding
that YouTube was right
and all the attention
and equity that I could've
built over that time.
I believe that a lot of people
here are getting so high
on the supply of being right
about crypto or blockchain
that they're glossing over
and thinking things like
social and mobile are
yesterday and we're gonna see
another seven to 10 year
foundational run for those platforms.
So please be thoughtful in
the way that you're mixing
your energies and your executions.
I believe that the things
that are current right now
are absolutely foundational
in your ability
to extract value from them for
what you're looking for to do.
A couple other things that
I think are important.
You need to understand the human
spirit in new technologies.
In 1996, I thought that by the year 2000,
every single person would come
into my dad's liquor store
with a cellphone and scan the barcodes
and know the price of
every wine in the country
and so I'd literally lower
the price of every wine
in my dad's story to cost or
the best price on the internet
because what I didn't
understand was how long
it would take to be accepted.
Online dating was in
play for over a decade
before it was culturally accepted.
I think a lot of people are
making bets on singularity,
on AR, on VR, on crypto, on blockchain.
You understand it.
You're beginning to understand it
and you're making decisions
based on your belief
that it will be accepted or at scale
in 24, 36 and 48 months.
No question, the thing
that makes me different
at 42 than I was at 24 is my understanding
at how much slower new technologies are
and how easy it is for
us to get into the bubble
of this conference and feel like everybody
knows what the fuck you're talking about.
But just for fun tonight,
when you go to the casino
or the strip club or
wherever the fuck you do,
when you go talk to normal
people about crypto,
pay attention that 99.9% of
the people on the strip today
have no idea what the fuck you just said.
(audience applauds)
Knowing I don't have a lot of time,
I'm going to say a couple other things
that are a little more macro and I'm sure
we'll do some stuff in Q&A.
The most macro thing I can tell you
is that self-awareness is
fundamentally the most important
shit I've ever seen in my life.
I am so addicted to this thought process.
If I could wish you
anything besides health,
it would be self-awareness.
Once you have self-awareness,
once you actually understand
who you are, so much crazy shit happens.
(audience applauds)
And so I'm unbelievably aware
that you have ambitions.
I think all of us have versions
of what we wish we were
versus understanding what we actually are.
You know, I would be thrilled to be
the starting quarterback
of the New York Jets.
That's not gonna happen.
But very early on in my life,
I was aware I was more likely
to buy the New York Jets
than to play for them and
what that allowed me to do
was to triple down on my
entrepreneurial spirit
as a 10, 11, 13-year old.
You know, if I could leave any
legacy from this talk today,
it would be to get somebody to understand
that maybe they're not a number one
and they should do a start-up,
but they're a number three
and should support the fuck
out of a great number one.
I always tell my entrepreneurial friends.
Number 12 at Facebook made more
than number one at 99.999% of companies
in the last 15 years.
If you can actually
understand what you're about.
A lot of you shouldn't be blogging.
A lot of you shouldn't be investing
and that is not a negative.
That's a positive and so I
unbelievably want to start
instilling things like
self-awareness and patience
because I can tell you one thing.
How many people are here under 30?
Raise your hands.
I really wish you knew what it felt like
to be 42 and I'm sure
a lot of people here.
How many people here over 40?
What all of you know that I know is
it's fucking crazy that 24
feels like 42 feels like 67.
It's always there.
It's always there and if you actually knew
how long, you know, one of
the most fascinating things
I'm paying attention to is
our inability to understand
how long our fucking life is.
The amount of people that go into crisis
at 18, 22 and 30 in our
society is laughable.
And so please understand that for me,
the biggest thing that I
could've delivered this evening
in this talk is putting
the timeframe of blockchain
and crypto into perspective.
I will also say one other very macro thing
that I think is super important for me
as you navigate how you're going to bet
your life in this world.
If you actually understand blockchain,
if you actually understand the framework
of what we're talking about here,
not what LitCoin's going to
be in fucking seven months.
No, the actual framework
of what blockchain means.
The thing that I have not
been able to really get
my head around that I'd be
fascinated and feel free
to DM me and talk to me about
it is I hope we all can accept
the following statement as truth.
If you actually understand
blockchain, it's really hard
to wrap your head around how
Russia, China and America
are gonna accept and allow this to happen.
I think it's very important
for everyone to actually understand this.
If you actually understand
what blockchain does,
it takes away all the
leverage that the countries
in our world have outside
of their atomic bombs and their armies.
It is a substantially big platform.
It is a revolutionary
2.0 of all the things
the internet, my friends,
has fundamentally
started to drastically impact our culture
because it's taken the middle
and it's giving it back to us.
All the political, not just the voting,
the things we talk about,
whether it's Me Too
or Black Lives Matters or anything else
that's even secondary
to those true issues,
I hope everybody understands
that all our shortcomings
as human beings have been protected
by the media infrastructures
of the last 100 years
and are losing their leverage
which is why we're having
different conversations
and making progress.
Blockchain takes that shit to
a whole fucking 'nother place
which is why it's far more vulnerable
than I think this room understands.
In parallel, while we think
about decentralization,
I hope you understand what's happening
across the world at a country level
because we're living through
the growth of nationalism, right?
If you think America is
putting up walls with tariffs
and actual debating walls,
go look at what's happening
in India right now.
Go look at what's
happening across the world.
We are now more than over,
over the last 70 years,
seeing countries build
internal mental walls
which are in complete
conflict with something
that looks like blockchain.
This is a very, very big deal,
one that is often not respected by people
that are enthusiasts of macro new trends.
Let me give you the comp
that will make sense to you.
When Instagram copied the
feature of Snapchat Stories
and pretty much pulled off
a pretty substantial punch
in the fucking face to
Snapchat, it created everybody
in the social media world to understand
that you better not build a
feature because an ability
of a company like Facebook,
Apple or something
of that ilk to copy that
and stop you from growing
is a very big deal.
If you look at what's happening
with the Scooter movement,
a lot of the cities and states
are not gonna get tricked
this time the way they did with Uber.
The internet has really
fucked up the status quo.
The people that have leverage
are not just gonna sit
with their fucking hands on their ass
and let blockchain do
a 2.0 version of that.
Please understand that
if you believe in Nirvana
of complete and utter blockchain at scale
that you're talking about
substantial World War
III fucking dynamics.
And so while everybody's
walking around and thinking of
short-term economics and the
quick scores they're making
on the currencies that's built
on top of these frameworks
and the flips they've made to
change their short term lives
which is phenomenal and
inspiring and super fucking cool,
I hope that there's certain people in here
that are starting to deploy
five, 10, 20 year windows
because if you are, and
you're thoughtful about it,
the economics, but more importantly,
the legacy that you can
leave becomes remarkable
and I promise you for
anybody in here who's made
a dollar or two in their
lives, very quickly,
money stops mattering and
other shit starts taking over.
So it's really fucking cool
you made a million bucks
on some bullshit crypto currency.
I don't give a fuck.
What I care about is you're actually here
which means you are
fundamentally 0.00001% ahead
of society in your opportunity.
I hope that you give the
meaningful thought process
and strategy against
this advantage you have
because when I saw people
have it with social
and when I saw people have
it with email and with search
and with the internet itself,
99.9% of them fucking blew it
because they were going
for the short-term score
because they didn't respect
in the macro opportunity.
(audience cheers and applauds)
You have one life.
Do something with it.
Thank you.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Thank you, thank you.